right yeah because if you come up to
vancouver there's no shortage of people
speaking all kinds of different
languages
we could get into a cab if we hail the
cab
there's a 50 chance the driver is
punjabi and a 50 percent is
arranged now i've been learning persian
so i can handle this i don't know
version as well
okay
[Music]
so and of course chinese there's no
shortage of china oh yeah do you guys
have
the cantonese i heard that vancouver the
canton well not just cantonese but the
someone told me that the poppy i forgot
the number it was a crazy number for
population yeah it's got to be yeah i
mean i would think that in uh in
vancouver it's got to be 35 percent of
china okay
yeah and that's all happened within the
last 20 or 30 years
and it used to be mostly people from
hong kong so it was heavy to cantonese
but now i think it's majority management
mainland china as well as taiwanese
origin people
but there's lots of everything certainly
i saw the filipino flag on one of the
videos so if you do tagalog we can find
you
pretty much everything we can we can do
pretty much anything like the only
languages that i haven't really cover or
um
dang what languages haven't i covered
have you done ukrainian i haven't done
any ukrainian yet
yeah i did i learned ukrainian i went to
ukraine a great country
how was
if you compare that to russian how like
how
well okay ukrainian is kind of between
russian and polish so the vocabulary is
more similar to polish but certainly the
writing system and and perhaps the
grammar is more similar to russian
uh it's not very difficult if you're a
russian speaker at first you listened to
ukrainian you know as a russian speaker
and i i felt i should be able to
understand this language but i don't
really quite understand it uh but then
if you put some effort into learning the
words uh
then um yeah and and uh this is slightly
different uh but but uh
i was you know
the interesting thing is that that
russian in terms of vocabulary is the
outlier the vocabulary is closer between
polish czech ukrainian and russian
vocabulary is somewhat different but the
grammar is very very similar okay and uh
yeah yeah and it's it's a nice country
good food and uh they unfortunately they
have a
real problem right now but uh i think
their new president is is good and and
certainly the it was a great country
but everywhere
yeah um what are your current like what
languages are you doing now like what
are your current active languages
okay so i initially thought i would go
after three so again going by regions
right so i got my east asian thing which
is you know chinese you know mandarin
cantonese
japanese korean to some extent
and of course i got my western european
languages romance languages you know
spanish french italian and so on
so i decided middle east like i don't
know enough about
so i decided to go after first i went
after arabic
and then i said well i i got the writing
system but there's so many iranians here
in vancouver so i should learn persian
and then my wife was watching uh turkish
soap operas on netflix so i started he
started it in a turkish but i dropped
the turkish for now because
it's just too much for me to do them all
at the same time turkish is is in a way
more difficult but because it's written
in the latin alphabet it's easier and uh
whereas reading for me like even though
i kind of know what the writing system
is in fact it takes a long time i don't
know how you handle all these different
writing systems because the brain you
know you can theoretically know
something but you actually i find you
got to do it so much before it starts to
feel comfortable
so right now it's basically persian and
arabic i'm just working on the two of
them i get podcasts off the internet i i
have people in one person an iranian gal
who's actually traveling in india and a
per and a woman in jordan and they
transcribed them for me and uh i i
listen to the podcast understand about
twenty percent and then i go through the
text uh on link and say words and
phrases and i'm just yeah so
okay so you're doing arabic and so which
one of those well
um
because i i believe that farsi for you
shouldn't be a problem with your
japanese background because the grammar
is the same but what do you think is
more
farsi farsi is not no farsi is turkish
in terms of the structure is more
similar to japanese but farsi is an
indo-european language so it's very
similar to other
european languages the word order i mean
nothing there is very strange whereas
arabic is yes
and turkish is stranger yeah
yeah but what you're learning from
what's which form of arabic are you
learning
or
just yeah well standard arabic i gather
there's a difference between fusa and
standard arabic whatever you want to
call it the standard arabic they're
modern okay
yeah because uh if i get on to al
jazeera or franz van gaal you know or
anywhere where they have arabic you know
podcasts political discussions whatever
it's all in standard arabic whether the
person is from sudan from uh algeria
from lebanon they speak the standard
arabic
uh i i recognize that if i were to go
and visit lebanon or egypt i'd have to
spend some time
uh working on that form of the language
but right now i'm focused on
on uh because that's the difficult part
when it comes to learning arabic because
you know if you like to speak with
people
i found that i found it to be a bit
difficult to try to level up
using modern areas then when you talk
with them using the modern then they'll
say well oh you
they'll they'll make some comments and
say you sound like my teacher or they'll
laugh
and they and a lot of times they don't
respond back and when they do respond
back it's in their respective dialect
you know so right
but but you know
i was in montreal and a lot of taxi
drivers are lebanese and they did not
respond in standard arabic on the other
hand
uh there's a coffee shop in vancouver
where i can speak to them in standard
arabic and my wife and i were in morocco
and taxi drivers
restaurant owners they were happy to
speak to me in standard arabic
even though we could have spoken in
french
you know right very common there but
they would humor me they were very nice
i like it when people humor me you know
not like that chinese guy who was giving
you oh man that was video
yes he's the only person in all of the
videos that looked of yours he was the
only guy who wasn't nice yeah that's and
that rarely happens i tell my you know i
i like to make
so when i have like a um a really
uncomfortable situation i think it's
good for the for the viewers too because
see they may have a similar situation
and they may get discouraged and say oh
i don't want to do this anymore this is
this how the people act but they need to
see i tell people that you can't really
expect every situation to be
positive but i would say 98 of the time
when you speak with people
you show them that you want to learn
their language they want to be very very
happy and they're going to be open and
they're going to be willing to practice
with you that situation with that
chinese guy that was really something
that rarely happens like i had out of my
experience but but i think i had two bad
experiences with chinese too
and i've been doing i've been doing
languages for 20 years
so i mean
but you have you have like not everyone
can do what you do like you have you
know it just bounces off you and you
come back with a chuckle and
i mean not everyone can do it right so
you have a very good personality for do
you come in with a chuckle before you've
even said anything you've already
created a bit of a positive happy mood
and stuff not everyone can do that and i
think some people would would get up
tight if if people were
annoyed or and he was just a jerk like
he claims that he spoke yiddish he
didn't speak yiddish and then he did he
challenged you and you spoke to him in
russia he says that's not russian and
then he told you your chinese was no
good like he was just
yeah yeah i didn't i didn't take him
seriously because i have too much
experience and you know i mean my
chinese are not perfect but you know
no and and i think that's another thing
that i i always mention you as an
example
like like i had a discussion with a guy
in japanese who was all about pitch
accent in japanese and pursuing sort of
the nth degree of perfection in japanese
and i said fine like if that's what you
want to do that's fine
but that's not the only approach one can
have to language learning and so and i
always point to you and say here's a guy
he's dabbled in estonian in khmer yeah i
think he did some hmong at some point
yeah swahili
like it's such a so he has sampled like
imagine you went to a buffet
dinner and you sampled a little bit of
everything that was at the table i mean
that's you can also just grab a steak
and sit down and eat the steak but i
think and i'm the same way like i have
20 languages i would say that you know
maybe a handful i speak well
and then it just you know it's
you know it gets worse from there on and
i i can't claim to speak but but i went
to greece and i spoke greek and i went
to romania and i spoke romanian
and if you came at me now in greek or
romanian i don't think i'd be able to
handle it but but so what i had that
experience i discovered i discovered a
little bit about greek culture and a
little bit about
i mean i tried vietnamese but i didn't
get very far but so i think that's a
tremendous thing to do and and you can't
expect if a person i don't know how many
languages you're up to now but
you can't expect that a person who does
50 languages is going to be
equally good in all of them yeah that's
just not realistic it's not really it's
just you know it's just i tell people
you know people ask me all the time well
you i see that you doing all these
languages at the same time but i will
always tell people if they're trying to
get to a really high level in the
language like you know c1 or c2 you
can't do right five or six languages at
the same time you have to really focus
on that language itself because that
language is going to require your full
attention you know i always tell people
i always tell people that so it really
all depends on the person it depends on
their goals or what they want to do like
me
i love i love the new experience you
know i love the the new experience and
new interaction with people so
i don't expect myself to learn all those
languages to a crazy high level so i
said i go and say look
i i'm happy with a1 i'm happy with a2
i'm not going to spend all this time
trying to get to like a c1 or whatever
you know so i i set realistic goals for
myself but i tell people all the time i
tell them you need to make sure
that um
you know set your goals um ask yourself
what you want out of this language why
are you studying this language
and um
if it's going to be a really high level
like that you can't unfortunately you
can't do multiple i mean you can but the
problem is going to the problem
you want to have is the attention you
know you you over here doing this and
then you say okay i'm do this for this
time and you over here you can't really
do that when you're trying to get a
language to a high level you have to
really focus on that language you know
so it really all depends i tell people
that all the time
[Music]
you